[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
as a community you know as a sheriff as
a father
obviously we are grieving the loss of
mia how the media coverage of gabby
potido now sheds light on lesser
publicized cases and right-wing
conspiracy theorist alex jones loses his
court battle after saying the sandy hook
school shooting was a quote giant hoax
plus a sexual assault probe into the
coaches of the national women's soccer
league which top attorney will have the
independent investigation and later
evidence the jury won't be able to unsee
experts detail the location of mark
gucci's cell phone on the night of sasha
krause's murder loud crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome to law and crime daily i'm brian
buckmeyer along with terry austin a
terrible end to the search of mia
marcano in orlando florida the sheriff
there says her body was found over the
weekend law encrimes and jeannette levy
is here with more on the case
brian the search for mia marcano spanned
three different counties the sheriff in
orange county florida said that a
maintenance worker who worked at her
apartment complex where she also worked
is believed to be responsible for her
death
everyone wanted this outcome to be
different orange county sheriff talking
about the discovery of a body believed
to be college student mia marcano 17
miles from her home she went missing on
september 24th detectives said armando
manuel caballero a maintenance worker at
marcano's apartment complex was the
primary suspect he had demonstrated a
romantic interest in mia this was
repeatedly rebuffed by mia sheriff john
mina said caballero was found dead of an
apparent suicide days later after
detectives spoke with him we now know
that a maintenance issued master key fob
which caballero was known to be in
possession that was used to enter mia's
apartment marcano's disappearance came
on the heels of gabby potito's
disappearance which garnered
wall-to-wall media coverage and public
interest the level of interest raised
questions about missing persons cases
involving people of color not getting as
much attention dr kathryn kuhlman is a
psychologist
when you look at gabby potito's case in
particular there's almost
this feeling you know we're very drawn
to it because you know as you watch the
vlogs and all of the social media that
she had posted you almost kind of get to
know her but kuhlman said there could
also be an issue of bias toward cases
involving white women we tend to focus
on cases where as a society we
collectively believe that the person
that is missing is you know this this
young person this ambitious person who
had so much to offer the world
and that's an issue systemically in our
society right that we you know
assign those values to to the white
people that are missing
and not necessarily to people of color
the hope is that other cases will
receive attention to bring the missing
home it was a plea mia marcano's family
had made
you know we will never sleep one night
until we get you home
we miss you we know that you're strong
now mercano's death has prompted
questions down there in the orlando area
about maintenance workers having a
master key to all of the apartments an
autopsy will be conducted to
positively identify the remains that
were found as mercanos and also to
determine her cause of death brian
thanks angeannette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney gigi gonzalez
and terry austin gigi the death of gabby
patino has brought light to missing
persons but also a reminder of how even
we the media have reported missing
people what about this case do you think
viewers should be focusing on when it
comes to missing persons
you know i think there's two key points
that viewers should really be focusing
on the fact that it's so easy that
anyone can become a victim of kidnapping
or of murder and you saw it here with
gabby petito where you know she was
kidnapped and alleged well potentially
uh you know murdered by her fiance and
in mercano's case where she was murdered
by someone she worked with and in other
cases where the victim didn't know the
person at all you know and it seems so
important that we highlight each and
every one of these cases so that we can
begin to get answers on their
whereabouts and what happened to them
like we saw here in marcano and where
we're beginning to see in potito
exactly terry with all deaths like this
there are questions of was it
preventable and who else is to blame how
do you answer those questions in the
death of mia marcano
you know i think it could have been
prevented brian this person who was the
primary suspect and who ultimately
killed himself he had a record he was
arrested in 2013.
he destroyed property on another campus
and he said it was a prank he had a bomb
like device and it damaged the property
and so what this school should have done
is a background check to make sure there
was no criminal record and it doesn't
appear as though they either did one or
they didn't reveal what his record was
so i think there is a claim here for
negligent hiring and i think we should
have done a more thorough job of making
sure those students were safe on their
campus behind closed doors
absolutely and jeanette how were
investigators able to locate mia
marcano's body about 20 miles away from
her apartment
well they actually used cell phone
records and they did that
with the suspect's uh cell phone they
determined that he was in that area the
night that she disappeared for at least
20 minutes and they said that that led
them to that area and to to search it
where they discovered the remains
thank you all for your update in this
case we're also seeing renewed interest
in the case of lauren cho who vanished
from her california airbnb in june and
hasn't been seen since
joe usually referred to as elle and her
boyfriend corey orrell had moved from
new jersey to bombay beach last december
the 30 year old who worked as a chef
baker singer and tattoo artist was last
seen in june oro said she left her
airbnb to walk into the hills between
yucca valley and morongo valley he
described her as upset and talking about
self-harm when she left he also said she
left behind her phone and didn't take
along any food or water police conducted
an aerial search almost a month after
she was last seen in late july the
airbnb property was also searched in
september interest in the case was
renewed after the gabby petito case
received national attention
meanwhile the search for gabby petito's
fiance brian laundry takes a turn north
of florida as reports out of the
carolinas claim he is hiding along the
appalachian trail
over the weekend fbi and law enforcement
officials received tips from witnesses
one who claimed he was face to face with
brian laundry who asked for back road
directions to california to meet with
his girlfriend law and crime obtained
the 9-1-1 call the man made moments
after the encounter
what makes you say that it was him i
wasn't sure about what he looked like
and then i got i went and parked
and pulled pulled up the photographs of
him and i'm 99.99
sure that was him
this comes after weeks of law
enforcement searching in florida where
laundry is last known to be seen in
early september reality tv star dog the
bounty hunter also claims to have found
some of laundry's personal items near
dusseltown florida laundry and his
family went camping in that same area
before his disappearance dogs
representatives say they've handed their
findings over to the fbi in hopes that
dna evidence can prove laundry was in
the area
still ahead on law and crime daily
sexual abuse allegations in the national
women's soccer league how the
organization is working to investigate
these serious claims but first how
infowars host alex jones lost big time
after spreading misinformation about the
sandy hook shooting all this and more
next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law lawn crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
infowars host and right-wing conspiracy
theorist alex jones loses two lawsuits
after claims that the sandy hook
shooting was a quote giant hoax
after not providing information for the
lawsuits brought forth by two parents of
the victims of the shooting a judge
ruled on thursday that he was
effectively lost the cases for not
complying with court orders jones became
infamous for his comments surrounding
the mass shooting falsely claiming that
it was a host conducted by paid crisis
actors who opposed the second amendment
in december 2012 a shooter entered sandy
hook elementary school and killed 26
people in a mass shooting 20 of the
victims were children in 2019 jones was
ordered to pay 100 thousand dollars in
court costs and legal fees to the
parents of sandy hook victims for
promoting inaccuracies about the
shootings in a trial scheduled for march
28 a jury will decide how much jones
owes the plaintiffs in this latest case
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney gigi gonzalez and terry austin
to crunch numbers on how much jones
could own terry what kind of claims
would the sandy hook family have against
alex jones and how are they proving they
were harmed or damaged
you know i think there are two primary
claims one is defamation and the other
is intentional infliction of emotional
distress which i've talked about in the
past both of them have to be intentional
or knowing and for defamation you have
to state something that is false and you
have to publish it meaning you have to
say it to a third party and you have to
demonstrate that there was harm or
emotional infliction of distress here
you have to show that you were
distressed and i think that the parents
in both defamation and intentional
infliction of emotional distress they
can show that they've had
emotional that they've had mental harm
that they've gone to see a psychologist
and they have records and bills to pay
for the damage that has been caused
because making claims like this about
your children who have been killed or
friends or family could be extremely
damaging as far as your mental psyche is
concerned absolutely as you said there's
probably a lot of proof that they can
provide to show that
what's the dollar amount of those kind
of damages what numbers do you think the
jury could be considering when
determining how much alex jones could be
on the hook for his comments
i think we're talking millions alex
jones published to the world that these
children who were murdered at sandy hook
were actually crisis actors and that
this mass shooting was a giant hoax
these parents were subjected to ridicule
threats and gaslighting and more all
while mourning the death of their
children i think the jurors are going to
be incredibly sympathetic to these
parents here absolutely i would tend to
agree there
especially considering who the victims
are in this type of case thank you both
jury selection is delayed by one day in
the trial of parkland shooter nicholas
cruz who allegedly attacked a jail guard
in 2018.
on monday a florida judge denied the
prosecution's request to delay the trial
but did agree to push off jury selection
by one day this comes as the defense's
lead prosecutor suffered an extreme
medical issue and is now recovering the
trial originally slated to begin on
october 11th has also been pushed to
october 18th cruz faces battery charges
for a december 2018 incident where
prosecutors say he attacked a jail guard
the trial is unrelated to the february
2018 shooting at marjory stoneman
douglas high school where crews
confessed to killing 14 students and
three staff members a day for that trial
has not yet been scheduled if convicted
in this case cruz could face a 15 year
sentence of attempted criminal battery
coming up on law and crime daily the
latest in the meta knight murder trial
and further testimony against the
accused u.s airmen plus the
investigation into the sexual abuse
allegations in the national women's
soccer league how the organization is
calling for change in the safety of
women's athletics
[Music]
welcome back u.s soccer hires former
acting attorney general sally yates to
lead a formal sexual abuse investigation
probe involving male coaches
in the wake of the usa gymnastics sexual
abuse scandal similar accusations are
making waves within the national women's
soccer league organization on thursday
claims against male coaches came to
light including north carolina courage
coach paul reilly who has allegedly been
sexually chorusing players since 2010.
washington spirit coach richie burke was
also fired after the washington post
reported that he verbally and
emotionally abused his players league
commissioner lisa bard resigned on
friday after the claim surfaced now u.s
soccer has hired sally yates to launch
an independent investigation to look
into the claims yates will be given full
autonomy to all resources for her
investigation the statement followed a
previous announcement that the nwsl
enlisted law firm covington and berlin
to investigate the same claims fifa
soccer world's governing body is also
running its own investigation
let's bring in criminal defense attorney
gigi gonzalez and co-host terry austin
to discuss terry with what we saw in the
investigation into usa women's
gymnastics what should we expect with
this investigation
you know the usa gymnastics took way too
long it was very slow they did not
believe or take it seriously and i think
we are going to see something just the
opposite here with the soccer league i
think sally yates is a former u.s
attorney she's a magna cum laude
graduate from law school she's worked at
king and spaulding which is a very
reputable law firm in atlanta and i
think she has an excellent reputation as
a former prosecutor and i think we will
see she will investigate this case she
will take the claims very seriously and
she will do the job that wasn't done
with the gymnastics
gigi that's a big part of this what does
it say that the national women's soccer
league is hiring sally yates to lead
this investigation with quote-unquote
full autonomy
i think that goes to show how serious
they're taking this i mean you heard
terry highlight all of sally yates
accomplishments this is a very
accomplished lawyer who specializes in
these types of investigations so the
fact that i don't think she would have
done this investigation if not without
full autonomy and complete access to all
resources in order to get to the bottom
of these allegations
absolutely we'll see how that
investigation continues again looking at
what happened with the usa gymnastics i
agree with terry we're going to see a
very full investigation and hopefully a
speedy one as well when they get to the
bottom of all of these allegations thank
you both when we come back the location
data specialist that took the stand in
the meta knight murder trial how expert
findings could be damning for the u.s
airmen accused of murdering a meta
knight sunday school teacher
[Music]
welcome back an update now and in case
we've been following closely here at the
lawn crime daily as a jury recommends
life in prison for stanley ford
last month ford was found guilty of
sending two deadly fires in his
neighborhood the case was handed over to
the jury after nine days of testimony
from experts investigators former
neighbors and friends of the victims
jurors deliberated for 14 hours over
three days in the end finding ford
guilty
nine people were killed in the fires
including a family of seven with kids
all under the age of 15. ford's charges
included 22 counts of aggravated murder
and aggravated arson on friday a summit
county cummins common pleas court jury
recommended that ford get life in prison
with no parole for the arson deaths the
jury also deliberated the possibility of
the death penalty but said that ford's
claims of mental health issues weighed
in this decision formal sentencing is
set for october 26th
it's evidence that may be difficult to
overcome for the united states airman
mark gooch on friday experts testified
where gooch's cell phone pinged the
night that sasha krauss was murdered
22 year old gooch is charged with theft
kidnapping and first degree murder of
krauss he pled not guilty on all charges
krauss was last seen in january 2020 her
body was discovered in february 2020
near flagstaff arizona prosecutors say
gooch drove from his air force base in
phoenix to krause's mennonite community
in farmington new mexico where he
abducted and later killed her an autopsy
determined krause was killed by a
gunshot wound to the head and blunt
force trauma prosecutors say gooch who
was raised in the mennonite community
had disdain for the faith the defense
argues gooch traveled to the mennonite
community to reconnect with the religion
on friday a location data specialist
took the stand describing where and when
gucci's cell phone pinged the night of
kraus's murder
so 1 13 a.m
this is going to be the last time we're
going to see this phone for a little
while but it's not going to leave this
area
the pin over to the right is going to be
where the the victim's body will be
recovered later and at 1 13 a.m
this device is going to drop off the
network and we're not going to see it
again it's back in that area with no
service
the next time we see that over here look
at the road real quick so this is still
loop road just so everybody's tracking
a paved road
and where the body will be recovered
technically there's two routes in there
just to the north and south
of that location so the last time we see
it is 113
and the next time we're going to see
that phone
will be in the same vicinity of sunset
crater
just to the west of it on its way back
to highway 89
and that area right by right here the
first time we see it there will be zero
three thirty three
so this is where we're going to get the
two hour and twenty minute gap so
this device goes stagnant somewhere in
this area in the vicinity to the east of
sunset crater for 2 hours and 20 minutes
gigi how accurate and trustworthy is
this cell phone location technology and
does this all but paint that gooch and
krause were together the night of her
murder
you know it's pretty reliable but i
think dishman's testimony was very very
reliable here he was able to walk jurors
through a map of gooch's whereabouts you
know and that's very compelling and the
fact that the defendant's uh cell phone
pinged near the scene of the crime
during the time of the crime in
commission is very compelling but on
cross he was not able to determine
whether or not he was within the church
or if uh he was in the force at the time
so i don't know if the picture is fully
painted here
now terry was the testimony of tracking
gooch and kraus's phone did that come
out clearly or do you think there were
opportunities for the defense to raise
doubts
well there was no doubt in my mind i
thought it was extremely clear as a
matter of fact when i listened to this
expert even when he was trying to tell
the jury something that didn't relate
specifically to gooch and this crime i
wanted to listen to what he had to say i
wanted to learn how it was peeing off of
one tower to the other and how the two
phones were together he made it very
interesting and based on what he said it
was clear in my mind that gooch was
definitely with krauss and that their
phones were together and they traveled
together and there's no doubt in my mind
that he was with her at the time of her
death so there might be some juries who
wouldn't believe this but i think the
way he testified on the stand the
details that he gave it was very
credible i mean that makes a lot of
sense there i know you've been watching
this trial and as we say it's not just
about what the person says on the stand
but how they say in terms of getting
credibility from the jurors so it sounds
like they got both terry thank you very
much as gigi thank you as well and thank
you for joining us here on lawn crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you